Going back to our Tsunami app code,
let's observe how the string builder is
being used to build up
the JSON string response.
So I'm going to go take a look
at the readFromStream method.
In the readFromStream method,
we have an input stream, and
we want to return a string containing
the contents of that stream.
So we create a new string builder and
we can start appending to it
all the lines of text available
in our buffered reader.
First, we set up our builder and
our reader, then we'll ask the buffered
reader for a line of text.
While the line isn't null, we'll append
that line to the string buffer and
read another line.
Eventually the buffered reader will run
out of lines and we'll use the toString
method to get and return the final
output from the string builder.
So as you can see, using the string
builder to gradually build up
the response string, is more efficient
than continually creating a new string
object each time we have more
content to add to the response text.